Is "Skinamarink" the "scariest film ever made"?
Or a nonsensical nightmare? Why not both?
Every year, a new horror movie comes along
that's billed as an all-timer. 2022 saw the
release of "Terrifier 2," an independent
slasher that became an unlikely mainstream
success story after it made fans physically sick
at screenings. This year, though, "Skinamarink"
is the hot new horror flick on the block that
people are already hailing as a future classic.
"Skinamarink" has, in fact, been described as
"the scariest film ever made" by some
shaken reviewers. That's high praise,
and it remains to be seen if it will stand the
test of time, but there's no denying that the
hype surrounding Kyle Edward Ball's debut
feature is exciting and morbidly alluring.
"Skinamarink" is the type of horror movie
that taps into the primal essence of fear,
according to the TwitterVerse.
One spooked fan posted,
Feeling "freaked out" was a common
response, with another fan posting,
Another fan, meanwhile, warned that the movie will
terrify even the most hardened and
experienced horror fans, writing,
Elsewhere, another moviegoer thanked "literal
jesus" that they didn't watch it alone, writing,
Furthermore, some horror fans have praised
"Skinamarink" for being original and
breathing life into a genre that's associated with
familiarity and death, like this fan, who wrote,
There are many horror fans out there who balk
at the thought of yet another found footage
movie. For some, the format has been overused
by too many low-budget filmmakers who don't
know how to make the most of it. When they're
at their best, though, found footage movies
thrust the viewer into the heart of darkness
and provide them with an immersive experience.
According to some fans, "Skinamarink"
is a prime example of found footage
horror at its best — right up there
with movies like "The Blair Witch
Project," "Paranormal Activity," and
"Cannibal Holocaust." At the same time,
Kyle Edward Ball's feature is a beast unto itself
that's comparable to nothing else. One fan posted,
"Skinamarink" is a horror movie
that favors mood, atmosphere,
and nightmarish qualities over a traditional
narrative, and explaining the plot would spoil
its ghoulish shocks and surprises. All you need
to know is that it revolves around two children
who wake up in the middle of the night
to discover that their father is missing,
and all of the windows and doors
to their home have disappeared.
As documented by Rotten Tomatoes, many
reviewers have commented on the film's
experimental qualities. In fact,
most viewers will probably come out
of "Skinamarink" scratching their heads
and wondering what they just watched.
At the same time, the movie taps into fears
that most people have been able to relate to
at some point in their lives — namely, being
a child and feeling anxious about monsters and
the thought of our guardians disappearing. Kyle
Edward Ball told Inverse that the confusion is,
to quote another recent horror hit, "all
part of the menu." Ball told the outlet,